foreign
Amy is with us in Salt Lake City hi Amy
how are you
I'm well how are you better than I
deserve what's up
good so we are on baby step three and
our family car has about 185 000 miles
on it and it's starting to give us
trouble and we're planning on driving it
till we can anymore but my question is
do we pause our baby step three and
start saving money for a newer
replacement
no baby step three is your emergency
fund
and your replacement is not yet an
emergency you're saying it may become
one
but right now it's not
and so you know since it's not an
emergency
um no uh I'm gonna drive it and
hopefully you can finish baby step three
and then save up enough to buy the next
car before it gives out on you if it
does give out on you before that then
some portion of the next purchase
becomes an emergency but you're going to
have to limit severely the car you
purchased to replace it
okay and if it does like stop working
before we finish baby step three what's
a good uh price for a car to pay while
we're still in baby step three if that
happens well the minimum possible
because transportation is the emergency
upgraded transportation is not the
emergency
okay so basically you know basic
Transportation I'm looking just for some
old beater that I can drive around
here's the thing you probably can patch
the car that you've got and make it
through this even if it lays down a
little bit I don't think it's going to
suddenly just completely the wheels fall
off the thing
it'll probably be a nickel and Diamond
drive you crazy for a little while and
I'd rather you do that then and buy the
proper car that's going to be a car you
keep for a little while
then uh you know buy a two thousand
dollar car and then later on have to buy
an 8 000 car
what's your household income
um 138. okay you're gonna get there so
fast it doesn't matter yeah yeah that's
the point and so yeah get there as fast
as you can that reminds me I think this
is a good insight for folks I remember
years ago uh Stacy and I were paying off
debt we were living in Atlanta and we
had the three little ones and we had an
older Suburban it was great thing ran
forever and the transition was starting
to go on it so we went took it in and it
was going to be about five grand to
replace the transmission well to me I'm
sitting there look at that going oh
until you do the research and you go
I've got the money and the five grand to
fix that thing the mechanic was like
it's gonna keep running for a long time
if you spend the five grand versus 15 or
20 or whatever else you do and so in
that situation it was a no-brainer to
replace the transmission and we got five
more years out of that car yeah and it
was still running when we sold it no oh
yeah here's the thing you there's uh
I would estimate and I'm making this up
but I'm not far off that less than five
percent of the time
do repairs make selling the car a better
situation you're almost always
mathematically better off to fix it yeah
and keep driving it I agree with that
fix it keep driving the thing that
happens though is twofold
um one is you start to have just this
down time in the hassle Factor yeah
starts to be just a complete pain in the
butt but mathematically not emotionally
not I'm worried about my wife ending up
on the side of the road at 10 o'clock at
night okay that not not that kind of
thing but just the math of the repairs
versus what I would spend to replace the
car it almost never makes sense to
upgrade in car but it does make sense
not mathematical sense to move up in car
because you get rid of hassle Factor you
increase convenience and reliability and
things that are not math but that are
quality of life yeah
and so yeah you do move up in car later
oh yeah and I'm telling you I was
reading something the other day depend
on the make and model and I'm not going
to get into this now but I mean it is
very normal now for a car to go into the
250 300 000 miles I mean I see old like
uh Land Cruisers which I'm into that
kind of older stuff yeah these cars have
250 300 000 miles on and they keep
running forever if you take care of them
oh there's a lot of models that'll get
three four hundred thousand if they're
taken care of